WENN DU DEIN LEBEN VERÄNDERN WILLST, MEIN
FREUND, MUSST DU NICHT NUR DEINE PHYSIOLOGIE,
SONDERN AUCH DEINEN FOKUS ÄNDERN.
WENN DU REICH SEIN WILLST, MUSST DU IM WAHRSTEN
SINNE DES WORTES ALLES GEBEN, DAS DU HAST,
UND DICH NICHT AUF DEIN GLÜCK VERLASSEN.
DESSEN MUSST DU DIR BEWUSST SEIN, UND ZWAR
SO SEHR, DASS DU DAVON ÜBERZEUGT BIST, DASS
DEIN VORHABEN GELINGEN WIRD.
DU KANNST NICHT UNTÄTIG SEIN UND DANN ERWARTEN,
EIN AUSSERGEWÖHNLICHES LEBEN ZU FÜHREN.
DAS WIRD NICHT PASSIEREN.
JEDE FÜHRUNGSPERSON WIRD DIR SAGEN, DASS
ES SICH BEI IHREM ERFOLG UM EINEN FORTLAUFENDEN
PROZESS HANDELT, DASS SIE NIEMALS DAMIT AUFHÖREN
SICH WEITER ZU VERBESSERN.
UND DAS BEDEUTET, DASS DU DICH STÄNDIG WEITERBILDEN
UND SOGAR NOCH MEHR EMOTIONALE BEHERRSCHUNG
ENTWICKELN MUSST, WEIL DAS ENTSCHEIDET, OB
DU HANDELST ODER NICHT.
ES GIBT DIE MÖGLICHKEIT ZUR SELBSTBILDUNG.
WIR MÜSSEN UNSERE BISHERIGE DENKWEISE BEISEITE
LEGEN UND DAMIT AUFHÖREN, ZU TUN, WAS JEDER
ANDERE TUT, NUR UM DANN VERÄRGERT DARÜBER
ZU SEIN, DASS ES UNS KEINEN ERFOLG BRINGT.
STATTDESSEN MÜSSEN WIR REALISIEREN, DASS
DIES DIE BESTE ZEIT IST, UM AM LEBEN ZU SEIN.
WÄHREND DU WÄCHST, LERNST DU.
DU BILDEST DICH UND ENTWICKELST WERTVOLLE
FÄHIGKEITEN.
ANSTATT DICH ALSO ZU BESCHWEREN, MUSST DU
DIR ÜBERLEGEN, WELCHE FÄHIGKEITEN AUF DEM
MARKT VON WERT SIND.
UND WIE ICH HÄRTER AN MIR SELBST ARBEITE
ALS JEDER ANDERE.
DENN SOBALD SICH MEIN WERT ERHÖHT, KANN ICH
MEHR GEBEN, MEHR ERREICHEN UND MEHR VERÄNDERN.
ALS ICH WARREN BUFFET NACH DER WICHTIGSTEN
INVESTITION SEINES LEBENS FRAGTE, DACHTE ICH,
DASS SICH SEINE ANTWORT AUF ALL SEINE UNTERNEHMEN
BEZIEHEN WÜRDE.
ER SAGTE ABER: „TONY, ZU DALE CARNEGIE GEGANGEN
ZU SEIN.“
ICH SAGTE: „WAS?“
„DEINE ENTWICKLUNG IST NÄMLICH DIE WICHTIGSTE
INVESTITION ÜBERHAUPT.
ZU LERNEN WIE MAN ANDERE ÜBERZEUGT, ZU LERNEN
WIE MAN SPRICHT.
OHNE DIESE FÄHIGKEITEN WÄRE ICH AUFGESCHMISSEN
GEWESEN.
ICH HABE IN DIESEM KURS GELERNT, EINFLUSS
ZU NEHMEN, UND DAS WAR DER WERTVOLLSTE SCHRITT,
DEN ICH JE IN MEINEM LEBEN UNTERNOMMEN HABE“,
SAGTE ER.
DENKE ÜBER DIESE AUSSAGE MAL EINEN MOMENT
NACH.
IST DIR BEWUSST, DASS JEDEM GENAU DIE GLEICHE
MENGE AN ZEIT ZUR VERFÜGUNG STEHT?
GENAU DIE GLEICHE MENGE AN ZEIT?
ÜBERLEGE MAL.
DU KANNST DEINE AKTIVITÄTEN PLANEN.
SORGE DAFÜR, DASS ALL DAS, WAS DU TUST, WIRKLICH
EINEN UNTERSCHIED MACHT.
SORGE DAFÜR, DASS DU DEINE ZEIT IN PRODUKTIVE
AKTIVITÄTEN INVESTIERST, DIE DICH NÄHER
AN DEIN ZIEL BRINGEN.
DIE EIGENSCHAFTEN, DIE DICH SONDERBAR MACHEN,
SIND TALENTE, DIE DICH ZU ETWAS BESONDEREM
WERDEN LASSEN.
UND GENAU DIESE EIGENSCHAFTEN MACHEN DICH
ANDERS UND AUTHENTISCH.
UND FALLS DU NICHT ZUR NORM PASST, DANN MÖCHTE
ICH DIR NUR MITTEILEN, DASS ICH MICH AUCH
NIE ANPASSEN KONNTE.
ES GIBT EIN BEKANNTES ZITAT, DAS SICH AUF
JENE BEZIEHT, DIE EIN VISIONÄRES LEBEN FÜHREN.
DIE PERSON, DIE DU IN FÜNF JAHREN SEIN WIRST,
ENTSTEHT DURCH DIE BÜCHER, DIE DU HEUTE LIEST,
UND DIE MENSCHEN, MIT DENEN DU DICH HEUTE
UMGIBST.
DAS STIMMT UND ES BEZIEHT SICH AUCH AUF ALLES
ANDERE, DAS DU TUST UND WIE ES DEIN ZUKÜNFTIGES
ICH DEFINIERT.
ALL DAS BASIERT AUF DEM, WAS DU HEUTE TUST.
IMMERHIN HABEN DIE LEUTE, DENEN DU ZUHÖRST,
DIE MEINUNGEN, DENEN DU GLAUBEN SCHENKST,
DIE BÜCHER, DIE DU LIEST, ODER DIE VIDEOS,
DIE DU DIR ANSCHAUST, ALLE EINE WIRKUNG.
ALL DIESE INFORMATIONEN, DIE DU AUFNIMMST,
EGAL OB POSITIV ODER NEGATIV, WERDEN DEINE
ZUKUNFT BEEINFLUSSEN.
DAS TRAINING, DEM DU DICH WIDMEST, ODER HALT
AUCH NICHT, WIRD SICH IN DEINER ZUKUNFT BEMERKBAR
MACHEN.
DIE ART UND WEISE WIE DU DICH HEUTE ERNÄHRST,
WIRD DEINE ZUKUNFT SOWOHL OPTISCH ALS AUCH
IN BEZUG AUF DEIN ENERGIELEVEL BEEINFLUSSEN.
DAS GLEICHE GILT AUCH FÜR DEINE GEDANKEN
UND INFORMATIONEN.
WAS DU DEINEM VERSTAND GIBST, WIRD SICH AUF
DEINE ZUKUNFT AUSWIRKEN.
WENN DU NUR MÜLL ZU DIR NIMMST, DANN RATE
MAL, WORAUS DEINE ZUKUNFT BESTEHEN WIRD.
STELLE SICHER, DASS DU DEINEN VERSTAND MIT
ERFOLGREICHEN GEDANKEN FÜLLST UND DICH MIT
MENSCHEN UMGIBST, DIE VON DEM GLEICHEN EHRGEIZ
ANGETRIEBEN WERDEN WIE DU.
ES IST EGAL, WIE DU DEINE INFORMATIONEN ERHÄLTST,
SEI ES VON BÜCHERN, PODCASTS ODER VIDEOS.
ES SPIELT KEINE ROLLE.
VERGEWISSERE DICH JEDOCH, DASS DU DEINEM VERSTAND
JEDEN TAG NAHRUNG GIBST.
DEIN ZUKÜNFTIGES ICH FLEHT DICH AN, ETWAS
DISZIPLIN ZU WAHREN.
DEIN ZUKÜNFTIGES ICH FLEHT DICH AN, NICHT
GENAUSO WIE ALLE ANDEREN ZU SEIN.
LERNE MEHR ZU ARBEITEN ALS ALLE ANDEREN.
SEI HÄRTER UND SCHLAUER ALS DIE ANDEREN.
DEIN ZUKÜNFTIGES ICH FLEHT DICH AN, JETZT
ZU SCHUFTEN, UM SPÄTER FREUDE HABEN ZU KÖNNEN.
WENN DU DEINEN VERSTAND NICHT REGELMÄSSIG
MIT ERFOLG FÜLLST, WIRD ER SICH MIT MITTELMÄSSIGKEIT
ZUFRIEDEN GEBEN.
DIE MASSNAHMEN, DIE DU TÄGLICH ERGREIFST,
WERDEN DEINE ZUKUNFT UND DAS, WAS DU IM LEBEN
ERREICHST, BESTIMMEN.
DU MUSST DICH ANSTRENGEN.
WENN DU ERFOLGREICH SEIN WILLST, MUSST DU
DICH ANSTRENGEN.
WENN DU FIT SEIN WILLST, MUSST DU DICH ANSTRENGEN.
WENN DU FRIEDEN HABEN UND GLÜCKLICH SEIN
WILLST, MUSST DU DICH ANSTRENGEN.
DEINE HANDLUNGEN WERDEN DEINE RESULTATE PRÄGEN.
MEIN VERSTAND IST STARK.
ICH BIN STARK.
MEINE GEDANKEN SIND STARK.
MEIN GLAUBE IST STARK.
MEIN LEBEN IST STARK.
SIE SAGEN, ICH KANN ES NICHT.
ICH KANN!
SIE SAGEN, ICH WERDE ES NICHT.
ICH WERDE!
SIE SAGEN, ICH BIN ES NICHT.
ICH BIN.
ICH BIN GRENZENLOS!
ES GIBT NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT SEIN KANN.
NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT TUN KANN.
NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT HABEN KANN.
IN MEINEM VERSTAND GIBT ES KEINE GRENZEN.
ICH BIN GRENZENLOS.
ES GIBT NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT SEIN KANN.
NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT TUN KANN.
NICHTS, WAS ICH NICHT HABEN KANN.
IN MEINEM VERSTAND GIBT ES KEINE GRENZEN.
SONDERN ETWAS, DAS DIE DINGE VERBESSERN MÖCHTE.
WIR WOLLEN BESSERE MENSCHEN SEIN.
ICH MÖCHTE MEHR SEIN, MEHR TUN, MEHR TEILEN,
MEHR ERSCHAFFEN, MEHR GEBEN.
ABER SO FUNKTIONIERT DAS IN DER REGEL NICHT,
WEIL WIR ALL DIESE DINGE HABEN WOLLEN.
WIR GLAUBEN, DASS SIE UNS GLÜCKLICH MACHEN
WERDEN.
DASS WIR WACHSEN UND EINEN BEITRAG LEISTEN
UND DANN PASSIERT DAS, WAS IMMER PASSIERT.
JEDER MÖCHTE EINEN TOLLEN KÖRPER HABEN,
ABER NIEMAND MÖCHTE DARAUF HINARBEITEN, RICHTIG?
WIR MÜSSEN UNS DARÜBER KLAR WERDEN, DASS
FORTSCHRITT IN GLÜCK RESULTIERT.
WENN DU WEISST, WAS DU WILLST, UND KONSEQUENTEN
FORTSCHRITT ERZIELEN KANNST, DANN WIRST DU
DEIN ZIEL ERREICHEN.
DU WIRST DAHIN GELANGEN, WO DU WIRKLICH SEIN
WILLST.
DORT, WO DU DIESES GEFÜHL VON LEIDENSCHAFT
UND LEICHTIGKEIT VERSPÜRST.
DIE ERGEBNISSE, DIE DU WIRKLICH ERREICHEN
WILLST, ENTSTEHEN.
ÜBERLEGE DIR ZUNÄCHST EINE FESSELNDE VISION.
WAS WILLST DU WIRKLICH?
WAS LÖST BEI DIR FREUDE AUS?
DIESE VISION MUSS SPEZIFISCH UND MESSBAR SEIN
UND, AM ALLERWICHTIGSTEN, DEINEN TATENDRANG
IN SCHWUNG BRINGEN.
DEINE GRÜNDE MÜSSEN STARK GENUG SEIN, DAMIT
SIE DICH AUCH DURCH DIE SCHWEREN SITUATIONEN
FÜHREN.
SETZE DIR EIN ZIEL, DAS DICH ANTREIBT.
DU BRAUCHST EINEN SCHLACHTPLAN, EINE LISTE
MIT DEN WICHTIGSTEN MASSNAHMEN, DIE DICH FÜHREN
UND DIR HELFEN, DEN ABSTAND ZWISCHEN DIR UND
DEINEM ZIEL ZU VERRINGERN.
UND DU MUSST DIR LEDIGLICH DIE AUSSCHLAGGEBENDEN
20% AN WISSEN ANEIGNEN, UM DEN GRÖSSTEN FORTSCHRITT
ZU ERZIELEN.
MACHE ZUM SCHLUSS EINEN GROSSEN SCHRITT NACH
VORNE.
WAS WILLST DU WERDEN?
WAS WILLST DU TUN?
WAS WILLST DU ERLEBEN?
WAS WILLST DU BEITRAGEN?
WAS WILLST DU GEBEN?
WAS WILLST DU MEISTERN?
WORAUF WILLST DU DICH DIESES JAHR FOKUSSIEREN?
WONACH SEHNST DU DICH WIRKLICH AM MEISTEN?
WAS WILLST DU IN DIESEM JAHR FÜR EINEN BEITRAG
LEISTEN?
WAS HAST DU GEPLANT UND WAS FÜR RITUALE WILLST
DU UMSETZEN, UM DEINE ZIELE ZU VERWIRKLICHEN?
BITTE MACH ES DIR ZULIEBE.
SCHAU DIR NICHT EINFACH NUR DIESES VIDEO AN.
MACHE GLEICH IM ANSCHLUSS ETWAS, DASS DICH
IN BEWEGUNG SETZT UND IN SCHWUNG BRINGT.
WENN DU NOCH HEUTE IDEEN IN DIE TAT UMSETZT,
DANN KANNST DU ALLES VERÄNDERN, ABER DU MUSST
DIE INITIATIVE ERGREIFEN, SOLANGE DU DICH
IN DIESER MENTALITÄT BEFINDEST.
UND ICH SAGE DIR, WENN DU JEMANDEN KENNST,
DER ZIELE UND TRÄUME HATTE, DIE ER UNBEDINGT
ERREICHEN WOLLTE UND IHM DIES AUCH GELANG,
DANN WEISST DU TIEF IN DEINEM HERZEN, DASS
AUCH DU DEIN VORHABEN UMSETZEN KANNST.
ES IST MÖGLICH.
WENN EINE ANDERE PERSON IHREN TRAUM VERWIRKLICHEN
KONNTE, DANN IST ES MÖGLICH, DASS DU DEINEN
TRAUM AUCH VERWIRKLICHEN KANNST.
WÄHREND DU DIR ÜBERLEGST WELCHEN WEG DU
EINSCHLAGEN MÖCHTEST, HALTE AN DIESEM GEDANKEN
FEST.
ES IST MÖGLICH.
ICH KANN MICH GLÜCKLICH SCHÄTZEN.
VIELES SPRICHT FÜR MEINEN ERFOLG.
ICH BESITZE EINIGE GUTE EIGENSCHAFTEN UND
ES BESTEHT DIE MÖGLICHKEIT, MEINE GROSSARTIGEN
FÄHIGKEITEN IN DIE WELT HINAUSZUTRAGEN UND
DAS ZU TUN, WAS ICH TUN MÖCHTE.
ICH KANN EIN EIGENES BUCH SCHREIBEN.
ICH KANN MEIN EIGENES UNTERNEHMEN GRÜNDEN.
ICH KANN AUF GROSSE REISE GEHEN UND DIE GANZE
WELT ERKUNDEN.
ICH KANN MEINEN SCHLECHTEN UMSTÄNDEN ENTKOMMEN
UND MEIN LEBEN NEU GESTALTEN, GANZ EGAL IN
WELCHEM LEBENSABSCHNITT ICH MICH BEFINDE.
DIE DINGE KÖNNEN SICH FÜR MICH ZUM GUTEN
WENDEN.
ES IST MÖGLICH.
ICH ERINNERE MICH GERADE AN ZWEI MÄNNER HIER
AUS CHICAGO.
SIE WAREN ZIEMLICH ERFOLGREICH UND ARBEITETEN
VIELE JAHRE FÜR EIN UNTERNEHMEN.
UND SIE WAREN UNTER DEN ZAHLREICHEN MITARBEITERN,
DIE ENTLASSEN WURDEN.
ES HANDELTE SICH UM ZWEI SEHR GUTE FREUNDE.
BEIDE SUCHTEN GEMEINSAM MEHRERE WOCHEN NACH
EINER NEUEN STELLE, NUR UM IMMER UND IMMER
WIEDER ENTTÄUSCHT UND ABGELEHNT ZU WERDEN.
SIE FANDEN KEINE ARBEIT UND SO GEHT ES VIELEN
MENSCHEN IN DIESEM LAND.
EINER DER BEIDEN GAB AUF.
ER WAR KOMPLETT ENTMUTIGT.
ER GING NICHT MEHR ZU BEWERBUNGSGESPRÄCHEN,
BLIEB ZU HAUSE, SCHAUTE FERN, BEGANN SICH
MIT SEINER FRAU ZU STREITEN UND BEHANDELTE
SIE SCHLECHT, TRANK BIER, TELEFONIERTE MIT
SEINEN ANDEREN PESSIMISTISCHEN UND ARBEITSLOSEN
FREUNDEN UND GAB SCHLIESSLICH EINFACH AUF.
DER ANDERE SUCHTE WEITER NACH EINEM JOB, GING
ÜBERALL HIN, WO ER KONNTE, UND HIESS JEDE
GELEGENHEIT, DIE IHM GEGEBEN WURDE, WILLKOMMEN.
ER ERKUNDIGTE SICH NACH STELLEN, TRAT IN KONTAKT
MIT LEUTEN UND BLÄTTERTE JEDEN TAG DIE ZEITUNGEN
DURCH.
ER GING ÜBERALL HIN UND VERSUCHTE EINEN JOB
ZU FINDEN.
„SIE HABEN ZU VIEL AUSBILDUNG.“
„SIE SIND ÜBERQUALIFIZIERT.“
„SIE WERDEN NICHT LANGE GENUG HIER BLEIBEN.“
UND ER MACHTE DENNOCH WEITER.
ER STELLTE SICH ERNEUT WO VOR UND SAGTE: „AUCH
WENN SIE MICH NICHT EINSTELLEN KÖNNEN, LASSEN
SIE MICH TROTZDEM HIER ARBEITEN.
ICH WEISS, DASS SIE MEINE TALENTE, MEINE FÄHIGKEITEN
UND MEIN WISSEN GEBRAUCHEN KÖNNEN.
ICH WILL NUR NICHT ZU HAUSE HERUMSITZEN UND
NICHTS TUN.
ERLAUBEN SIE MIR EINFACH EHRENAMTLICH BEI
IHNEN ZU ARBEITEN.
SIE MÜSSEN MIR AUCH NICHTS IM GEGENZUG GEBEN.
ICH WILL EINFACH NUR ARBEITEN.
ICH WILL EINE BESCHÄFTIGUNG HABEN.“
MAN SAGTE IHM: „IN ORDNUNG, DAS IST IHRE
ENTSCHEIDUNG.
ABER ERWARTEN SIE NICHT, DASS SIE ETWAS DAFÜR
BEKOMMEN.“
UND ER WAR MORGENS DER ERSTE, DER INS BÜRO
KAM, UND ABENDS DER LETZTE, DER NACH HAUSE
GING.
VIER WOCHEN SPÄTER KÜNDIGTE EIN HOCHRANGIGER
MANAGER UND SIE SUCHTEN NACH EINER NEUBESETZUNG.
UND RATE MAL FÜR WEN SIE SICH ENTSCHIEDEN.
SIE ENTSCHIEDEN SICH FÜR DEN MANN, DER DORT
OHNE GEGENLEISTUNG ARBEITETE.
ER BEKAM DIE STELLE.
WAS UNTERSCHEIDET DIE BEIDEN MÄNNER?
DER EINE SAH MIT SEINEN AUGEN UND DER ANDERE
MIT SEINEM VERSTAND.
DER EINE BEURTEILTE DIE SITUATION ANHAND DESSEN,
WAS ER SAH, UND BEURTEILTE DANACH WIE DIE
DINGE SCHIENEN.
ABER DER ANDERE INTERPRETIERTE, WAS ER SAH.
DER EINE SAGTE, ES IST UNMÖGLICH.
ES IST VORBEI.
ICH BIN AM ENDE.
ICH KANN NICHT MEHR.
ICH SCHAFFE ES NICHT.
ICH GEBE AUF.
ICH WURDE IMMER UND IMMER WIEDER ZURÜCKGEWIESEN.
ICH VERSUCHE ES NICHT MEHR WEITER.
ES GIBT DA DRAUSSEN KEINE JOBS.
DER ANDERE MANN VERLOR SEINE HOFFNUNG JEDOCH
NICHT.
TROTZ ALL DER ABSAGEN UND ZURÜCKWEISUNG,
TROTZ DER SCHLECHTEN WIRTSCHAFT, TROTZ DESSEN,
WAS DIE ZEITUNGEN BERICHTETEN.
ER HIELT TROTZ ALLEDEM AN DER HOFFNUNG FEST,
DASS IRGENDWO IHM JEMAND EINEN JOB GEBEN WÜRDE.
ER GLAUBTE EINFACH WEITERHIN DARAN, DASS ES
MÖGLICH WAR.
UND GENAU DAS MÜSSEN WIR TUN, UM UNSERE TRÄUME
ZU VERWIRKLICHEN.
DENN MANCHMAL GESCHEHEN DINGE IN UNSEREM LEBEN,
MIT DENEN WIR NIEMALS GERECHNET HÄTTEN.
WENN SOLCHE DINGE PASSIEREN, WILLST DU WOMÖGLICH
AUFGEBEN.
ABER GIB NIEMALS AUF!